all right so the Super Mario Brothers
movie is now out digitally and after
re-watching this movie I yeah I I've
realized that this movie is chocked full
of Easter eggs so instead of doing a
full scene by scene breakdown I wanted
to touch on as many Easter eggs like
Mario's hat look at his hat that his his
Hat's got to be one right
[Music]
dang Mario no need to panic buddy so
grab your overalls ground pound that
like button and block smash subscribe to
stay up to date on all things heavy
spoilers now here we go
all right so this opening Bowser
entrance features his flying Castle
Fortress that was first introduced back
in 2000's Paper Mario for the Nintendo
64 console this made a few more
appearances later on but also has some
DNA from Bowser's lava layer that was
featured in Super Mario Galaxy 2.
Bowser's Army features a bevy of Koopas
as they're clearly separated into ranks
by their shell color greens look to be
kind of privates Reds are more like
sergeants and blues are commanders now I
I'm probably getting those ranks in
verbage all wrong but it's because of
what their shells are capable of doing
in Mario Kart with green shells being
the most pedestrian red shells will
track the character as blue shells
always hit their Mark the magic Koopa is
Bowser's trusty wizard named kamik and
he's made several appearances over the
years and in games but was first
introduced as the main villain in 1995
Super Mario World 2 Yoshi Island the
Bowser flags that the Koopas are flying
are similar style to those at the end
levels that Mario has to pull down from
the poles in order to complete the
levels in the 2D games the little
penguins Bowser faces off with are
modeled after the big old penguin that
you can race on the cool cool mountain
in Super Mario 64. or if you're a real
Menace to Society you would rescue the
baby and before delivering it back to
his mother you just you drop him off the
edge
[Music]
Bowser uses his flame breath which is uh
you know been a staple ever since his
first appearance revealing that the
Penguins had been hiding a giant
question block something that we know
would give players coins power ups or
even decoys in the Mario games cracking
open the block Bowser gains a power star
in incredibly valuable item in the games
that allowed Mario or I guess whoever to
become invincible for a brief amount of
time in later iterations they were used
as Collectibles or even a form of
currency in the Mario Party games the
Mario Bros Plumbing commercial features
a classic tune called the plumber rap
and nostalgic fans will know that this
is pulled directly from the 1989 live
action Super Mario Brothers Super Show
with the Mario brothers and plumbings
again we're not like the others who get
all the fame another nod to the Super
Mario Bros Super Show is the woman in
this Plumbing commercial this is the
voice of Genie Elise who voiced Princess
Peach in that series along with Birdo
and shy guy the commercial shows Mario
and Luigi flying like superheroes and
this is a fun nod to the Cape Mario
power-up that first was introduced in
the 1990s Super Mario World that allowed
Mario to float through levels and attack
enemies by spinning the cape the map
Mario scoots the car across has
references to many of the storefronts
that we'll talk about and see later but
uh yeah I just just wanted to point that
one out great attention to detail funny
enough the web address that's featured
in this commercial is real but also fake
for their Plumbing business full with
service areas and testimonials from
customers including a one star review
from their former boss Spike spike who
we later see in the pizzeria was the
main antagonist for from the 1985 video
game Wrecking Crew which surprisingly
featured the Mario Bros as construction
workers before their own game as
plumbers later that year the phone
number from the commercial also works
allowing you to listen to a cute little
answering machine message from Charlie
days Luigi thank you for Super Mario
Bros Plumbing it's Samia Luigi if you
need service please text us at the same
number you just called the restaurant at
the Mario Bros watched the commercial in
is called Punch Out Pizzeria a nod to
the boxing game by the same name where
you box as Little Mac going through the
ranks like Rocky a lot of your opponents
in the game are also portraits on the
walls including Bear Hugger King Hippo
Mr Sandman and glass Joe amongst you
know others funny enough Mario also
makes an appearance in this game as a
referee two small portraits of duck hunt
are also amongst the fighters on the
wall now duck hunt was a pack in game
that came with the original Super Mario
Bros game on the Nintendo and along with
that there's a little tiny green and
white flagpole that was the original
design from the Super Mario Bros games
behind the Mario Bros an older gentleman
is playing a jump man arcade cabinet and
this is modeled after the Donkey Kong
arcade cabinet looking at the cabinet
artwork and Screen featuring The Classic
level 1 layout in its initial release
the protagonist of the game was simply
referred to as Jumpman but little Mario
in the cabinet sale brochure
um it even has the same classic sound
effects the older gentleman named
Giuseppe looks awfully similar to Mario
in his design and this character is
voiced by the original Mario and Luigi
voice actor Charles martinet who also
did every iteration of the character
until this movie he even voices Mario's
father as almost a passing of the title
or lineage the news broadcast behind the
Mario Bros mentions mayor Pauline who
was the mayor of new Doc City in the
Super Mario Odyssey game but also first
appeared as the Damsel in Distress in
the original Donkey Kong arcade cabinet
the Ticker on the bottom mentions stolen
vegetables being recovered by the Ice
Climbers a shout out to the duo of popo
and Nana from the 1985 Nintendo game by
the same name along with Hogan's alley
in obscure shooting range light game
similar to duck hunt Luigi's ringtone is
the classic GameCube startup screen
[Music]
and the caller ID image is that of a
faceless me of which was first
introduced on the Wii as a player
avatars in Wii Sports and other Wii
titles this might be a stretch but when
Luigi hangs up the phone stating we got
one maybe a Sly nod to 1984's
Ghostbusters when they get their first
call as well thank you
we got one
I mean Luigi does deal with ghosts in
Luigi's Mansion so I mean he he would be
a fan of Ghostbusters right right
Mario's car keys have the same classic M
that's featured on his cap along with
the windshield of their van featuring a
sticker that looks awfully similar to
the Nintendo seal of quality that I
remember being on a lot of my Super
Nintendo games the newspaper rack that
they run by features a paper called The
Daily 8-bit a reference to the original
Nintendo system being an 8-bit Council
the truck behind them has a design
that's modeled after the game and watch
game fire where you had to kind of save
people from a burning building by
catching them but here it looks like
it's updated a little bit with the Mr
Game and Watch character collecting
Falling Fruit a game watch character
also is on the sign in the construction
zone that the brothers run through now
the construction zone is modeled after
world 1-1 in Super Mario Bros where the
paint cans small boxes and green boards
being the same layout as the blocks and
pipes in that level even the Castle
burger sign is supposed to be the
flagpole with the restaurant being the
castle at the end of that level the
ritzy family has a painting that looks
like an artistic interpretation of a
Monty mole on their wall along with a
glass sculpture of a Pikmin from the
2001 game by the same name hanging
blocks that look similar to any Mario
level and the husband is seen reading a
book with the title Galaxy featuring a
logo similar to that of Super Mario
Galaxy the gold red and blue pipes below
the bathroom are are definitely featured
in a Mario level or two I I remember
playing this I can't think of what
exactly this one is but they're level
dressing rather than ones that you
actually go down so please in the
comments let me know what level I'm
thinking of it's driving me crazy
there's a whole look at Mario's extended
family which is honestly a bit weird but
illumination said that they were based
on released in Nintendo sketches with
little to no alterations so uh I guess
you know they had Mario's Family planned
all the way back then so uh the the more
you know on the wall there's pictures of
Mario wearing his classic Mario Tennis
attire him as a baby with a familiar
design and him and Luigi in graduation
gowns which maybe follow me here maybe
an obscure reference to Mario teaches
typing a non-nintendo computer game
released back in 1992. on the shelf
behind Mario's dad there's a couple of
uh sheep with sombreros referencing the
Sheep herding challenges from Super
Mario Odyssey the table behind him has a
phone that looks like a teal Nintendo
switch joy-con controller one of the two
original colors aside from the black and
gray variants in a meta within meta
nature Mario scene plane Kid Icarus on
the original Nintendo console and
throughout his room there's a treasure
Trove of Nintendo nostalgia with a
picture of a man golfing in the same
position as the box art of Nintendo's
golf his calendar has the same artwork
as the original excite bike box art
there's a model of star Fox's r-wing on
the top of his television set a
wrestling poster hyping up a big match
between Starman and the Amazon from the
original Nintendo pro wrestling game
below the golf picture is the box art of
Nintendo's tennis game and on the other
wall there's a sunglasses wearing polar
bear from the Ice Climbers game Captain
Falcon's race car the Blue Falcon from
the f-zero games and posters for
Nintendo's Kung Fu baseball and
potentially what is Nintendo's track and
field during the news report the bottom
ticker references underground crab
sightings which is not a euphemism but
is actually referencing a sidestepper
enemy in the Mario Bros arcade game a
signal from the star system
fs176 which is the Talon system from the
action-adventure Metroid series of video
games and ryoda I believe hey Ami who is
considered the main character of the N64
game Wave Race 64. so I wouldn't be
surprised if Nintendo was trying to
build out this big old Nintendo Universe
there's another reference to duck hunt
with the French restaurant
which literally translates to duck hunt
and features a similar looking mallard
duck featured in those games Mario and
Luigi walk past a level one two sign
with a familiar musical Cube playing in
the background
[Music]
this is the same music that begins to
play when you pipe down to the second
part of level 1 AKA level one two
[Music]
the giant pipe Luigi is sucked into are
of the same color and shape as the
classic warp pipes that are used
throughout the Mario games to get into
you know hidden areas or warp to
progress through the levels there's also
a classic pipe sound when the two are
split into different areas and pipes
toad is seen wearing his classic outfit
from most of the games along with his
backpack that he wears in his own
spin-off game Captain Toad treasure
Tracker a few notes of his theme song
actually play when Toad is first
introduced a group of Bitty buds stroll
through the scene which are common
enemies first appearing in Super Mario
3D Land but more commonly Captain Toad's
treasure Tracker and another enemy is
the Bram ball which first was introduced
in 2009's new Super Mario Bros for the
Wii Princess Peach's castle looks
identical to that from the Super Mario
64 game even having the stained glass
window above the entrance as the
familiar inside the castle walls theme
from the game plays
[Music]
Luigi winds up in the dark lands the
Koopa troops main base of operations
first appearing in the 1988 Super Mario
Bros 3. it kinda has more of a Luigi's
Mansion feel as he runs across
swoop-like bats from Mario Galaxy dry
bones and shy guy enemies in his Escape
Luigi mutters Mario where are you which
might be again one of those weird
obscure references in this video
referring to a 1980s commercial for the
Mario Bros game where Luigi mutters this
same expression
foreign
Luigi smashing into a dry bones chasing
him triggers a familiar sound of jumping
on one of these dudes heads in the games
and Dry Bones reforming is you know just
like the games the Mushroom Kingdom is
packed like everything here is basically
an Easter egg as the Toad's banking
system is based on coin blocks these
little Treasure Chest icons above them
are also the same chests in the Toad
Houses from the Super Mario Bros 3 video
game various symbols throughout Mushroom
Kingdom in this toad Village that kind
of relate back to different cups in
Mario Kart 8 can be seen the mushroom
cup flower cup Leaf cup amongst others
Mario and Toad walk about a storefront
called crazy cap which is a chain of
clothing and cap stores that appear in
the Super Mario Odyssey game same colors
and logos and everything here The
Lovable Toadette is of course you know
missing from this movie but she is
featured here on a poster in the
background with a couple of other toads
the antique store is filled with old
school Mario items like Dragon Coins
from Super Mario World Super Bells from
Super Mario 3D World keys from a Yoshi's
Island a boomerang item from Super Mario
3D Land along with shortcut hammers
p-blocks P balloons music boxes in ax
weapon and spring that first appeared in
the arcade game Donkey Kong Jr my
favorite reference in all of this though
is the shop owner telling the toad
that's buying the old cartridge to blow
on it if it doesn't work and that it
should do the trick of course this is an
old urban legend that every single kid
would do to their cartridges if they
just didn't work when he first put him
in now the funny thing is you weren't
supposed to do this at all because it
was actually damaging the connections
between the cartridge and game console
because of moisture buildup but hey we
were all dumb kids we we didn't know
better there's a couple of fruits
alluding to our boy Yoshi who is
unfortunately missing from this movie
with Mario eating an apple that's also
referenced or shown in the super Mario
World video game and the circle
watermelon fruit from Yoshi's Island
where you could chop that thing down and
then spit out the seeds like
the map above the elevator Mario and
Toad get off on has a similar design of
the Super Mario Bros 3 world 2 over map
with a desert setting palm trees and
even the castle design when Mario and
Toad arrive at Peach's castle the guards
say the princess is in another Castle
which is exactly the message players
received when they finished a world in
the first Super Mario Bros inside the
castle there are familiar looking
paintings similar to the ones you jump
in and out of in the Super Mario 64
castle setting the battle map in Peach's
Throne Room features a couple of classic
Overworld locations like Yoshi's Island
and Sarah saland the home of Princess
Daisy where we first meet her in Super
Mario Land so maybe maybe that's where a
sequel goes the whole obstacle course
setting feels like it's inspired by
Super Mario Maker taking bits and pieces
from various Mario games and settings
and just smash them them all together
into an unbeatable cluster sandbox of
creative nonsense near the end of the
obstacle course Peach uses her dress to
slowly float down to safety which was a
move first implemented in Super Mario
Bros 2 where Peach was able to float for
a short amount of time as her special
move Mario does a couple of his classic
moves during the obstacle course
including the ground pound or hip drop
to bust through some blocks climbing
jumps and the Super Mario 3 p meter
sprint with his arms out by his side I
love this one Ed Bowser's party pretty
much any and all enemies are present
from Koopa troops Hammer Bros piranha
plants spineys Goombas boom booms shy
guys sniffets chain Chomps and bombs the
rock band members are kind of
reminiscent of some of the kooplings
from Super Mario Bros 3 though not
identical two of them have similar
looking hairstyles to Larry and Lemmy
well the third is rocking sunglasses
like Roy's but uh with a much smaller
body size and later on when Bowser is
playing his piano the brand of piano is
that of a lewd wig von Koopa yet another
Koopaling and also if you didn't know
this all of the kooplings are named
after famous musicians the Bowser
statues lining the outside of this party
are similar to the ones in you know many
of the various games but instantly made
me think of the punch a bunch minigame
in Mario Party 8. flashbacks to their
childhood gives us a look at baby Mario
and baby Luigi the infant versions of
the Mario Bros first introduced in Super
Mario World 2 Yoshi's Island and then we
also later get you know a baby version
of peach when traveling to the Jungle
Kingdom to gather the Kong Army Mario
and Peach and Toad travel through
several familiar lands like the first
babam Battlefield from Mario 64. for
what looks like cheap cheap beach from
Mario Kart 8 the sand Kingdom from Mario
Odyssey Yoshi's Island which doesn't
feature our iconic green boy and rock
candy mines from new Super Mario Bros U
the music Bowser and kemek jam together
to is another rendition of the level 1 2
underground theme from the original
Super Mario Bros and of course was
featured earlier in the sewer section
there's a whole Field of Fire flowers of
power up that allows the person to throw
fireballs and usually turns Mario's
outfit into you know his red shirt with
white overalls instead but here it
changes Peach's outfit to the same color
palette even having the fireball make
the same sound effect when Peach first
makes one appear
[Music]
the cages Luigi and the others are
thrown in over The Lava are similar to
the ones that have held Peach in the
games which kind of alludes to Luigi
taking her place throughout this movie
because yeah
um from this moment on the dude is
completely sidelined amongst the
prisoners is a blue Luma named lumili I
I absolutely love this pessimistic
outlook on life this fun character but
just dreary as hell but he's from the
Super Mario Galaxy game who acts as a
shopkeeper type selling life and one-up
mushrooms also his inclusion in this is
a big hint to the sequel where it might
potentially go with Super Mario Galaxy
and introduced Rosalina who serves as an
adoptive mother for all of the Lumas at
the Kong Fortress the first thing is the
Rhino looking hood ornament on the
Kong's go-kart and this I'm saying is a
nice reference to ramby the rhinoceros
an animal buddy that you could ride in
the Donkey Kong Country game the Kong a
bouncer throwing a banana behind him
only to have another cart completely
spin out of control is your classic
Mario Kart reference a la banana trap to
protect your rear and then using a
glider to fly the rest of the way is
something that was added into the Mario
Kart series when Mario Kart 7 came out
and drastically changed that gameplay
DK's entrance into the fighting arena is
the grand spectacle at this point really
reminded me of like a Thor and Hulk's
battle in Thor Ragnarok but the infamous
DK rap accompanies his showboating and I
love how they Incorporated this but it
was originally in Donkey Kong 64 and
unanimously was like thought to be one
of the worst songs ever
throughout this there are tons of Kong
references obviously Donkey Kong dating
back to the original arcade machine but
also Cranky Kong and Diddy Kong from
Donkey Kong Country 1 Dixie Kong from
Country 2 and Chunky Kong from Donkey
Kong 64. funny enough some
some Donkey Kong Jungle Beat Bongos are
sitting right next to the group this was
a rhythm-based game that kind of
surprisingly started the music-based
game fad leading to Guitar Hero and rock
band I mean it was a year earlier than
Guitar Hero so it so it had to be right
there's also a random Kong wearing a 64
shirt referring to the N64 the arena
also has familiar red girder beams blue
ladders and barrels reminiscent of the
original Donkey Kong arcade cabinet that
we first saw these two face off in a
couple of power-ups are featured in this
section the first being the blue mini
mushroom first introduced in Mario Party
4 and would shrink whoever you know used
it there's also the super Bell power up
allowing the person to transform into a
cat being more agile in their movements
first introduced in Super Mario 3D World
Donkey Kong uses a couple of his
signature moves from his games like the
barrel roll from the original Donkey
Kong country game and the giant punch
his neutral special move from Super
Smash Bros on the N64 cranky Kong's
cabin is very reminiscent of his cabin
from Donkey Kong Country with a similar
rocking chair on the outside rather than
that of the inside there's also a nice
picture of Funky Kong surfing the dude
that provided transportation in the
earlier Donkey Kong Country games and
sketches of cart designs and a trophy
that you'd win if you got first place in
Mario Kart cranky Kong's map has a
similar art style and layout of the map
from Super Mario World featuring the
same lands in Peach's throne room from
earlier the entire Mario Kart section
from prep to rolling out to the battle
that ensues with Bowser's Koopas feels
like one big homage to Mad Max Fury Road
heck even some of the Kongs are wearing
pads and armor reminiscent of that movie
we're just missing a big old guitar
shredded in Diddy Kong or Dixie or
someone the attention to detail when the
three create their carts is beautiful
because the three selection Wheels
cartwheel and kites featured are
identical to that cart selection screen
in Mario Kart 8. even the sound effects
attributed to this are the same and the
final selection button has an A on it
being the same button you'd confirm with
you know an N64 Wii or Nintendo switch
Mario's cart not not Mario Kart but like
the cart Mario picks is the standard
cart selection with peach selecting the
standard bike Peach is also rocking her
bike jumpsuit outfit from Mario Kart 8
which she wears when she's driving a
bike or a TV cart toad is driving what
looks like a variant of the Tiny Titan
cart from Mario Kart Wii which is
fitting because this only is available
for smaller drivers and Toad is a
smaller driver and there's even a small
glimpse of the bullet bike vehicle
driven by one of the Koopas later my
nostalgic heart was so happy when they
all Drive on Rainbow Road in iconic
Mario Kart course that has many
different iterations dating back to
1992's Super Mario Kart and they even
included the iconic shortcut made
popular in Nintendo 64 version of
rainbow road after jumping off the edge
only to cut off like half of the course
throughout this karting chaos Mario
drifts a few times which is a move that
you'd basically have to do if you want
to win races rewarding the driver with a
small boost as you can see a couple
times here and then the anti-gravity
hover wheels that were first introduced
in Mario Kart 8. a bevy of Mario Kart
weapons are also used like bananas both
throwing them behind and ahead of the
characters green shells again both
throwing them ahead and behind bullet
bills even though they didn't physically
turn the driver into a Bullet Bill like
they did in Mario Kart or they do and
some bombs and of course the infamous
blue shell that would track down whoever
was in first place and completely up
there day it even circles Mario and DK
like it does in the games all of the
Kongs are snatched up by Bowser's Koopas
using little clown copters a vehicle
Bowser has traveled around in a couple
of times that was first introduced in
the final boss fight in Super Mario
World after Mario and DK fall into the
ocean they are swallowed up by Amare now
many fans of Mario 64 will know that
this guy as the nightmarish eel that you
had to avoid and then grab a star from
his tail in Jolly Roger Bay there's also
a cute little blooper swimming about the
ocean the two are able to escape using a
DK rocket Barrel looking uh kind of
similar to the ones that are used in
Donkey Kong Country Returns but were
actually first introduced into the
Mythos back in Donkey Kong Country 3.
shown earlier when cooking but toad
pulls out his trusty frying pan as a
weapon which you know is of course a lot
of people will know this a weapon that
peach utilizes in a lot of the Super
Smash Bros series of games but actually
originated all the way back in Super
Mario RPG as Peach's best weapon that
she can acquire when Bowser is
practicing his wedding proposal he wears
a similar looking white hat to the one
that he wears to the wedding in Super
Mario Odyssey and the flowers that he's
holding are smaller piranha plants a
common enemy that is found in almost all
of the Mario games kamek dressing up as
Peach to help Bowser with his proposal
is a reference to the new Super Mario
Bros for the Wii where he did the exact
same thing tricking you into thinking
that you had in fact saved the princess
now a similar thing happens in Mario and
Luigi Dream World on the Nintendo 3DS
but he doesn't wear the wig in that
version at the wedding the cake toppers
look similar to the cake toppers at the
wedding in the end of Super Mario
Odyssey but the cake in general seems to
take influence from the Super Mario
adventures comic which ran for 12 issues
in the Nintendo Power Magazine heck
Bowser is even seen wearing a white
tuxedo in this comic so maybe Mario
Odyssey and this movie are actually
borrowing from this Source material
there's a couple of familiar faces that
attend the Bowser impeach wedding one
being King babam one of the first bosses
you face off with in Super Mario 64 and
King Boo who first appeared and was the
main antagonist in 2001's Luigi's
Mansion also great attention to detail
when King babam sits on a green Koopa
his shell pinballs back and forth in the
Pew much like the shells react in many
of the Mario games an iconic white and
green spotted Yoshi egg is on the gift
table for the wedding and uh we'll talk
about this later so shh Peach pulls out
and uses an ice flower the opposite of
the fire flower which can basically
freeze enemies and sure this was
featured in later games but its first
appearance was in a 1992 Japanese Mario
manga called Superman Mario Kun yeah
yeah it that's kind of weird throughout
this action sequence Mario busts out
even more of his classic moves like the
hip drop that we talked about earlier
but also his spin jump and surfing on a
Koopa show that were both featured in
the Snowman's Land level in Mario 64. he
grabs new power up the super Leaf which
allows Mario to wear and use the skills
of the Tanuki suit allowing him to fly
with his tail similar to when you grab
the suit in Super Mario 3 and then you
fill up the P meter reaching platforms
and clouds far above the level Bowser
launches what he calls a bomber bill
which is essentially the same as a
bonsai bill from Super Mario World
they're like bullet bills but you know
obviously way bigger now the funny thing
is Mario's stopping it with his tail and
in Super Mario World aside from you know
jumping on the top of it or ducking
below and completely avoiding it a
well-timed spin jump could actually
defeat these guys the Bonsai bill after
getting you know tail whipped then takes
on characteristics of a bullseye Bonsai
tracking Mario like a homing missile
this is either a great homage or I'm a
reaching hard here but Mario is spit out
in a construction zone back in Brooklyn
with the cityscape behind him and this
is a wonderfully weird reference to the
1993 Super Mario Bros live action movie
where Mario and Bowser merge with New
York City in a very similar setting both
locations having similar attributes a
construction area with the Brooklyn
Bridge being shown behind them a lot
more of the Brooklyn storefronts and
advertisements are seen here with the
first being a car wash billboard
featuring a balloon Fighter character
from the game well balloon fight there's
a donut shop that's a nod to the donut
shaped blocks littered throughout some
of the classic Mario levels a Sunshine
Travel Agency a nod to the Super Mario
Sunshine on the GameCube featuring the
same logo and font an ice cream shop
called a blizzard pop which features the
polar bear wearing sunglasses from the
Ice Climbers Nintendo game game I mean
this is like the second time this guy
showed up he's getting too much screen
time a drugstore featuring pills on its
sign that have the same shape and
coloring of the pills featured in the
various Dr Mario games red yellow and
blue a disc goon hardware store which
maybe is the most obscure uh reference
here referencing the mascot discune for
the Japan only famicom disc system that
was released in 1983. a little sign that
says save the kingdom being a self-aware
message to Mario saving the Mushroom
Kingdom and a playing card company
billboard for Lucky cards a nod to
Nintendo's Origins starting with their
playing cards all the way back in 1902
and the ace pictured here looks like the
ace design from their Middle Ages deck
Mario and Luigi grabbed the Power Star
together allowing them both
invincibility the both of them glowing
almost a rainbow color is a nice
reference to the look of Mario morphine
into you know multiple colors when
obtaining one of these in the games and
the familiar Power Star invincibility
track plays when it's activated
foreign
[Music]
moves the Mario Bros use on Bowser is
the tail throw technique used in Super
Mario 64 during the Bowser stages but
unfortunately missing is Mario's
catchphrase of so long what well well
you know what it is
[Music]
during the mid-credit scene we can see
Bowser now trapped in the cage residing
in Princess Peach's castle and I'm
saying that the cage is a slight little
nod to the cage that you have to jump
into for Boo's big haunt level in Mario
64 in the outside garden area and the
final thing to end all of this is the
post-credits tease of our green boy
Yoshi hatching out of his egg the little
green dinosaur man that first appeared
in 1990s Super Mario World as we get a
late Stinger of Yoshi's vocals as it
then turns to black
[Music]
oh
now Yoshi's not entirely the last of the
last of the last Easter egg in this
video because this whole scene of
weaving through the destruction of the
underground Rubble only to end with an
egg hatching is a direct reference to
the critically acclaimed well well not
not really I'm just I'm just saying that
uh 1998 movie Godzilla where the very
last scene of that movie is pretty much
exactly this last Yoshi stinger and that
is it every little big obscure weird
obvious Easter egg we could find in the
Super Mario Bros movie of course there
are dozens if not hundreds of sound
effects and musical cues that we may
have missed but I I didn't want this
video to be longer than the actual movie
so please let us know uh some subtle
sound effects or musical cues that you
really enjoyed and stuck out to you
obviously this movie is jam-packed full
of Easter eggs hidden things heck things
we probably miss like when Mario and
Luigi bust through the wall in the
underground section the shape of the
hole in the wall is the shape of Mario's
8-bit head yeah who who would have
guessed not me that that that's for sure
but yeah let us know in the comments
what some of your favorite Easter eggs
were and where do you want to see a
sequel go for the Mario movie because I
need I need a Super Smash Bros crossover
huge type movie soon give it to me now
uh anyway this video took a lot of time
but please let us know if we missed
anything again let us know in the
comments because uh there's probably
dozens of things but yeah last month we
ran a competition giving away three
copies of the quantum Mania steel book
and the winners of that contest are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want to further support this
channel for as little as 99 cents a
month then click the join button below
and as a thank you you'll get early
access to videos every week you'll
you'll be in like this elite special
group we also have our merch store over
at xeroedition.com which sells a lot of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats all sorts
of things we recently launched our
Peacemaker and Drax inspired t-shirt so
if you want to head over there now and
help us out then the links are in the
description and of course if you want
something else to watch we have some
videos right over there we're ramping up
more classic movie breakdowns so treat
yourself with all of that out of the way
thank you again for sitting through this
huge long video it's been it's been a
big one but I've been your host Jared
I'll see you in the next one take care
and peace